battez les gens qui fabriquent et
jean-benoît la regina on va en racheter
gb - dans la résidence avant racheter tu
te calmes d'accord il faut que j'en
parle
c'était tout cas être comme ça en
tournage et qui sont basses et la 10ème
année son boss au travail des mois et
des mois malheureusement plus
l'ambassadeur bueno la régie et c'est un
artiste qui a besoin de ces kinder bueno
six équipes et des appalaches et le
tournage de partir aubry a tout arrêté
s'il est arrêté de fumer il ya au ces et
vic et mystères vie je suis avec vous et
je vous emmène dans les coulisses de mon
nouveau clip
vt parce que s'il ya bien un style de
musique que je dis moi si j'avais pu
j'aurais terreur juste voir le respect
de la stricte mais c'est pas gagné
[Musique]
jamal ont des problèmes parce qu'on a vu
un ski alors ça c'est mon sermon square
c'est ça notre salut brut
ça me cision directs causés par trouver
ça pas mal de mes vidéos mais aussi
également bas qui bosse avec moi qui
font du sont douces c'est messi qui se
recrutent aujourd'hui mais figurant de
luxe john laing dire bonjour à caméra
arrière où la caméra les skis à dire
ayez à les décors qui sont en 3d
les décors qui sont en 3d sont réalisés
par cet homme et d'autres jeunes et
toute l'équipe de renard 61 qui ont fait
un tabac de malades en plein jour puis
jour huit jours ce qui pourra voir le
décor de new york de las vegas et tous
vous ne le savez pas iasi rue il ma
maison mais ça arrive c'est juste après
c'est juste là va aller avec mon revers
va sur le fait alors move toujours la
porte d'en avant qu'elle véhicule dans
lequel je rentre c'est mon habitude
alors voilà les choses à moitié la fiat
panda on a laissé au garage ma voiture
on a sorti le mercosur g ça fait un peu
plus rêver en terme de vitesse j'ai ce
que je veux dire une bonne pointe de
bandas c'est à 122 123 km heure en fond
de cinquième
on y sent 30 mais c'est tout c'est tout
à fait une dernière
vas-y micro faire un peu et fait comme
si tout vrai coupé
aujourd'hui je suis en lieu sûr
[Musique]
bonojean 15 tu l'as entendu on passe à
los angeles et à new york pour tourner
de la côte ouest los angeles la ville
des anges
[Musique]
je suis un joueur de football américain
le football américain est un sport qui
se pratique avec une équipe d'attaquant
le but étant de mettre ce ballon ovale à
travers la zone d'en but derrière tenue
dans près tout des revenus mais dernière
ville c'est los angeles los angeles
c'est le flou un peu de détente un peu
cheap un peu hype
en fait moi finalement sur me rends
compte que c'est moi cette ville je suis
les parties
le faire parce que je tapais respire
j'ai plus vite plus vite qu'on rembourse
france à la main on pense au confinement
gouvenement complètement tout seul
présent goisque rénovation 87 les
angoisses mois qu'ils ne s'effondrent
pourquoi la fial maintenant au tournant
voilà c'est ça que je lisais voilà c'est
ça le vrai décor la vraie image que le
tueur
là je mate los angeles tu vois ce que
bédié tu vois ce que je veux dire
et non suis pas à los angeles je suis
actuellement longjumeau le dauphin
c'est ça la magie hausse et bouriane la
réflexion ce qui est acquis et on y
écoute c'est un truc qui est en train
d'arriver là et c'est assez assez
révolutionnaire c'est qu'en fait on
recrée complètement des décors en 3d
qu'on peut ré incrusté dans les murs de
l'aide pour créer les sentiments de
profondeur et d'intégration complète
c'est assez bluffant
tout le travail de lumière qui est fait
là dessus pour pouvoir donner
l'impression qu'on est vraiment au sein
des rues ou des décors qui n'existe pas
en fait
et ouais c'est plutôt bluffant moi c'est
la première fois que je tourne dans ce
genre de technique de technologie et
franchement c
l'instance est vraiment superbe le fond
quoi j'ai su que mandaloriennes avec
cette même technologie
donc je suis pas peu fier ce que je
regarde la série j'adore voulait
proposer un visuel un peu différent et
donc la brède sur vettel on est sur mon
clip je pense qu est le plus c'est le
plus poussées en termes d'effets
spéciaux peu changé de main dans la main
280 je vais regarder un mec
charismatique il arrête de la pitié
devant brut en fait c'est un gros médias
le fameux fichier d'un il fait tout le
temps ça oui pour pour rabaisse les
autres pour se sentir à l'aise dans sa
peau
bon les gars ont dernière scène c'est
partir à les dernières scènes s'arrête
jamais tu étais date le vais aller samia
ou la non allez on y va aller sur le
site
ça va tourner vite la foule thierry
à léon joseph en tournage magie à tous
merci à vous de m'avoir suivi pour ce
tournage
on se revoit très vite abonnez-vous à la
chaîne de brut mais également à la
mienne à ma page instagram est allé voir
le clip
vettel qui est disponible sur youtube on
se revoit très vite sur les internets
[Musique]